okay Percy Jackson sea of monsters so
Percy Jackson sea of Monsters is the
next Percy Jackson movies based on the
Percy Jackson books and I'm sure people
are going to compare this movie to Harry
Potter and say is a Harry Potter ripoff
I respectfully do disagree Harry Potter
movies are beloved movies based on
beloved books the Percy Jackson movies
are based off of beloved books but
they're movies that people just don't
really give a about no they don't
care no one cares they care in that way
that they care because it's on like
they're at home they're like alright
Food Network Stars / what's on HBO Percy
Jackson I guess I'll watch it while I
still can't find Waldo is one elusive
bastard so Percy Jackson it is pretty
much Harry Potter and if we're just
getting it out there it is it's true
instead of a school that can't have a
school because that would really be
ripping Harry Potter off so now they
hang out at day camp they're hanging out
at summer camp they're at camp candy for
special people who are half God's and
now Percy Potter Hermione and black Ron
have to go out there and save the day
it's an interesting premise it is and in
that I can say the books are probably
good but this movies just not good as
weak characters portrayed by weak actors
I don't even know if the actors are weak
I'm just saying they're not good in this
movie the heroes are generic the
villains are cookie cutter Kevin Bacon
ish is just gonna be a big baddie it's a
mess and you can tell they're holding
back because the whole thing is made for
kids at least in Harry Potter you had
death spells you felt like kids could
die even though kids weren't dying at
least not yet
this movie just has no suspense it's
they get this Golden Fleece that can
raise people from the dead at that point
you're like alright anyone dies I just
thinking it brought back to life there's
no suspense there Percy Jackson has this
pen that he clicks and turns into a
sword that's awesome that's great when
he's going up against dudes what does he
do starts hitting them with the handle
of it because my god it's a kid's movie
you can't slaughter people and cut them
down which is kind of like Leonardo and
Ninja Turtles he has his swords and in
the movies he can't just like slash a
foot soldier down the middle knowing
it's a disgruntled teenager that double
just be bad I guess although that would
be awesome to say but at least Leonardo
if he's not gonna slaughter people with
his sword he'll do some hurricane kick
he still has his ninjutsu Percy Jackson
doesn't know how to fight he does new
all he has is his sword that he
hits people with the butt of
just pretty much the least effective way
to use that swords like yeah yeah good
job kid be a handicapping yourself on
purpose that now you're just dumb I do
like how they mix lore into our world I
like seeing that kind of stuff it's
really creative but again I feel like
that's a concept that's in the book so I
give the books credit for that this
movie just takes the concepts from the
books and just doesn't make it I haven't
read the Percy Jackson books I don't
know they could be a piece of but I
just feel like they're better than this
movie there's not much to say about
Percy Jackson honestly there really is
not the trials that people are going
through you're like alright you're gonna
do this and of course you're gonna end
up bonding alright that's pretty cliche
of course you're gonna get this idea and
you're gonna show her that you're
actually a warrior alright yeah that's
pretty cliche everything that happens in
this movie is the most uninspired and
lazy way to go about it that Harry
Potter was too polished in every way
shape and form don't worry you got Percy
Jackson here for you because of the
generic entertainment factor for kids
and the fact that I like Greek mythology
and they do incorporate that into our
modern world well enough for kids I'm
not gonna dog this movie up I want
to but I'm just not going to I will say
you're not gonna remember this movie in
t-minus a few hours yep already forgot
coolest part is with the Cyclops one
scene in the movie is the coolest part
of the movie it's kind of like having a
herpes outbreak here like well that one
day didn't hurt as much as the other day
it doesn't make it good right so generic
fantasy movies that try to be Harry
Potter that just failed miserably at it
something that you can tell is trying to
fill the Harry Potter void and just
isn't quite hitting it whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you